My husband grew up eating Pop Tarts
and Toaster Strudels,
and this morning he was craving them,
so I decided to make him a hybrid
out of both a Pop Tart and a Toaster Strudel.
Started by adding my dry ingredients into a food
processor and slowly dropping in some cold butter.
I let that go until it resembled the size of pebbles.
For my dry ingredients,
I whisked up an egg,
added a splash of milk,
made sure that was all combined
before I added that to my dry mixture.
It was a lot easier plopping it on a work surface
and kneading it for a little bit,
so that's what I did
before I wrapped it up in cling film
and put it in the fridge
while I got started on my filling.
I was debating between raspberries and strawberries,
but strawberries won,
so I added them to a pot with some honey and lemon.
When they were cooked down,
I blended them up,
added some cornstarch,
and let that thicken
before putting that in the fridge to cool.
In the meantime,
I rolled out my dough and cut it into six pieces.
I wanted them a little bit smaller than usual,
so I did that
before spreading some of the strawberry filling on top.
Then I placed a second piece of dough on top of that
before using a fork to seal the edges
and poke some holes in the top.
I let them bake for about 30 minutes,
and then pulled them out and let them cool
while I started on my glaze.
He loves lemon,
so I decided to go with a lemon glaze for these.
I didn't want it really thick,
so I decided to make it a little bit thinner,
and they were done.
Lucky walked in at the perfect time to try these,
and he absolutely loved them.
I'd never had a Pop Tart or Toaster Strudel before,
but these were really good.